when it comes to for example food
insecurity School food programs again
you can always pour money into any
program and at the margins create change
I mean there's no doubt that pouring
money onto anything will create change
in a Marginal Way the question is how
large is the margin and how big is the
movement right so the Delta is what I'm
looking at and so I I think that the
you're you're starting at a second order
question which is what if we ignore what
I would think are the big primary
questions of Education namely family
structure value of education at home how
much you have parents who are capable or
willing to help with homework what are
the incentive structures we can set up
for a society that actually facilitate
that how local communities take
ownership of their schools is a big one
right all all of these issues we're
ignoring in favor of say air
conditioning or lunch programs and so in
a vacuum if you say air conditioning and
lunch programs sounds great in a vacuum
in in terms of prioritization of values
and cost structure are those the things
that I think are going to move the
needle in a major way in terms of public
policy I I I do not and I in fact I
think that many of them ends up being
disproportionate wastes of money I me
I've talked before pretty
controversially about the fact that an
enormous amount of school lunch programs
are thrown out like an enormous amount
of that food ends up in the garbage can
is there a better way to do that if
there is a better way to do it then I'm
perfectly willing to hear about that
better way to do it but it seems to me
that one of the big flaws in the way
that many people of the left approach
government is what if we hit every G
with a hammer and my question is what if
theat isn't even the problem what if
there is a much Bigg substructure
problem that needs to be solved in order
to if you're shifting de chairs on the
Titanic sure you can make the Titanic
slightly more balanced because the deck
chairs are slightly better oriented but
the real question is the water that's
gaping into the Titanic right yeah and I
agree with you 100% but again the I feel
like we're on the conservative merry
around then of never wanting to address
not a conservative mer go round I can I
can give you 10 ways well sure but so
like here would be the merry round I
would say that like there's a minimum
funding for schools that I think would
help children and we go well the thing
that would help them the most is two
parent households and I go okay well two
parent households actually aren't the
problem um the issue is access to things
like birth controls that people don't
have children early on and it's like but
the issue isn't actually birth control
the issue is actually you need a certain
amount of money to move out early and to
get married and then to have a two
parent household so it's actually like
Economic Opportunity no well it's you no
just two parent households that's yeah
but like what is the what are the prec
people before you're married and
have babies sure done that's great we
can say that and try to fight against
you know however many hundreds of
thousand of years of human evolution but
people will have sex and people will
make babies and then they used to get
married the vast majority of people in
this country with kids used to be
married the vast majority of people with
kids in this country now are not married
increasingly that obviously a societal
change something changed it wasn't human
evolution but a lot of those things in
terms of resting on whether or not
people get married have to do with
financial decisions do you have the
money people are worse off now than they
were 5060 years ago when the marriage
rates were higher people are delaying
the start of their careers because
education is going increasingly
important so in in other words people
are richer now and they have more
education now and yet they're having
more babies out of wedlock now because
they're richer and have more education
I'm saying that the one of the biggest
indic for whether or not somebody's
willing to get married is how much money
both people are making if they can move
out of their household people don't tend
to want to get married at 22 when
they've just finished College when they
don't have the money to move out and
they can't afford a house because we
have changed the moral status of
marriage in the culture meaning that
everyone poor Rich and in between used
to get married that is by the way a huge
percentage of marriages in the United
States used to be what they would call
shotgun marriages meaning that somebody
knocked somebody up and because they did
not want the baby to be born outside of
a two- parent household they would then
get married do we think that shotgun
marriages though are a way to bring back
equilibrium to education that if we yes
absolutely yes 100% a child deserves a
mother and a father because that is the
basis for all of this including
education do we think that shotgun
marriages are well let's say this do we
think that that's a reasonable direction
that society would ever take or is this
like yes it was the reasonable direction
for nearly all of modern history was but
history Moves In One Direction right why
because because of time people people
don't think that a in in what in what
ways and I don't think we've ever like
regress social standards back to like oh
well let's go 100 years back and do
things that you know used to exist
before I the entire left right now is
arguing that we regress social standards
by rejecting Row versus Wade so that's
obviously not true the Row versus Wade
is not a social standard it's a Supreme
Court ruling number one number two what
if you read the actual majority opinion
on roie Wade we can see that socially we
ever actually never made huge progress
on how Society viewed abortion this has
always been an incredibly divisive thing
right even that was I think part of
alito's uh writing on it was that things
like gay marriage for instance we've
kind of moved past and it's not really
as debated anymore but abortion was
never a settled
topic The Arc of History constantly
Moves In One Direction is be lied by
nearly all of the 20th century what do
we mean by that I mean I
mean barbarism communism Nazism all of
that was a regression from what was
happening at for example the beginning
of the 19th century in the 20th century
what in what way Nazism and communism
wen't a regression from what was these
are well in terms of like communism
being a regression for instance I'm not
a communist but like the
industrialization of the Soviet Union
happened under communist Society the
industrialization murder of T of
millions of people that a regressional
regression which is what we talking
about now moral regression and you're
you're suggesting that moral regression
I wouldn't term a return to Traditional
Values a moral regression you would but
your suggestion is that history only
Moves In One Direction and I'm
suggesting that history does not only
move in in One Direction it tends to
move actually back and forth sure I
don't think that all of history moves in
one uh One Direction there going to be
Wars there are going to be times of
peace I think in general we're more
peaceful now than we have been in the
past but I think when we look at the way
that people live their lives I think
that we tend to move in a certain
direction socially so when it comes to
things like racism or when it comes to
things like slavery or women's rights I
think that there are two huge things
that probably aren't changing in the US
and one is access to contraception and
one is women working jobs I think that
these two things are probably huge
things that are moving us off of shotgun
marriages or getting married very early
on and I don't see though do you think
that those two things are going to
change fundamentally first of all what
the data tend to show is that actually
more Highly Educated people as you were
saying tend to get married more so the
idea is that women getting an education
somehow throws them off marriage it's
the opposite usually not educated those
women AR getting shotgun marriages those
women aren't having children now now
you're Shing the topic my my topic was
how to get more people married and what
I'm s and then then you suggested that
higher levels of Education are delaying
marriage and making it less probable and
what I'm telling you because this is
what the data suggests is that actually
as you raise up the the educational
ladder people tend to be married more
than they are lower down on the
educational ladder if you're a high
school graduate you're less likely to be
married than if you a postdoc I agree
with you but that's because one of the
biggest precursors to getting married is
having like a level of economic
stability so as people get more educated
they obtain this economic stability and
then they're in a more comfortable
position to explore more serious
relation there's another confound there
I mean the confound is that people in
stable marriages tend to be the children
of stable marriages and there's only one
way to break that cycle which is to
create a stable marriage and that is
something that is in everyone's hands
again this notion that it is somehow an
unbreakable unshadow barrier to get
married and have kids I don't understand
where this is coming from why is that
such a why is that such a challenge
chall I it's unbreakable or unshatter I
was just the initial point was for
school if we can provide a minimum level
of educational stuff for children that
probably be good but when we Retreat
back to well it has to be the families
that are fixed first fixing families is
a multivariant problem so many I am fine
within my local community we all vote
again I I've suggested that there's a
difference between local community and
federal I'm fine with my local community
voting for school lunches or air
conditioning or whatever it is that we
all agree to do because the more local
you get the more homogeneity you get in
terms of interest and the more interest
you have in your neighbors all of that's
fine I'm part of a very very solid
community in our community we give to
each other we have minimum standards of
helping one another all that's wonderful
when it comes to the actual problem of
Education what I object to in the
political sphere and this happens all
the time is everybody is arguing on top
of the iceberg about how we can move the
needle 0.5 percentage Point as opposed
to the entire Iceberg melting beneath
them and we just ignore that we pretend
that that's just you know sort of the
natural consequence of thing the Arc of
History suggests that people are never
going to get married again well I mean
actually what the Arc of History
suggests realistically speaking speaking
is that the people who are not getting
married are not going to be having kids
and what it also suggests the people who
are married are going to be having kids
and so the demographic profile actually
over time is rather going to shift
toward people who are having lots and
lots of kids I'm married I have four
kids everyone in my community is married
that's like minimum buying in my
community is four kids okay and so
what's happening actually in terms of
demographics is that the people who are
more religious and getting married are
having more kids and so if you're
talking about the Arc of History
shifting toward I I would suggest that
actually demographically over time long
periods of time over one generation over
long periods of time the only cure for
low birth rate is going to be the people
who get married and have lots of kids
yeah I don't necessarily disagree with
any of that but I'm just saying that
again on the I know you're upsite when I
bring up the term marry gound um I think
that there are good conversations to be
had about people getting married um
because stable families produce stable
children that are less likely to commit
crime that are more likely to go to
school that are more likely to product
members of society ET ET I'm not going
to disagree with you on any of that all
of that is true um it's just frustrating
that sometimes when you bring up any
problem all of it will Circle back to
other things that makes it seem like we
can't make any progress in any area
without like fixing I literally just
told you that on the local level I'm
fine for people voting for so for
instance on the local level so for
school funding school funding is done I
think generally per District so what do
you do when you have poor districts that
can't afford air conditioner for their
schools I mean the idea there would be
that presumably if the society meaning
the state and I generally don't mean the
federal state I mean like the state of
California for example decides that
everybody ought to have air conditioning
people will vote for air conditioning
and that's perfectly legal and I don't
think there's anything morally objection
about that per se I also don't think
that that's going to heal anything
remotely like the central problem and I
think that what what what tends to
happen in terms of government is people
love arguing about the problems that can
be solved by opening a wallet and nobody
likes to solve a problem by you know
closing their sex life to one person for
example or having kids within a stable
religious community like the things that
actually build
Society I'm fine with arguing about each
of these policies and and whether we
apply them or not is a matter generally
of pragmatism not morality it's a matter
of incentive structures not per se
morality because incentive structures do
have you know moral underpinings there
there's such a thing as you know for
example if you're going to use a welfare
program you have to decide how effective
it is to what crowd it applies where the
C offs are does it disincentivize work
does it not dis all of these are
pragmatic concerns but on a moral level
the generalized objection that I have to
people on the left side of the aisle is
that they like to FOC in these
conversations very often it feels as
though
it's a conversation with with people who
are drunk searching under the the lamp
for their keys the problems they want to
look at are the problems that are
solvable by government and then all the
problems they don't want to look at
which are the actual giant monsters
luring in the dark and not particularly
solvable by government are the ones they
want to ignore and assume are just the
natural state of things and I don't
think that's correct at all and I one
billion per agree but then obviously my
criticism for the conservative side is
the exact opposite where where there are
Parts where government could remedy some
issues um for instance you know uh
children having sex with each other and
producing other children out of wedlock
like sometimes having after school
programs is nice to prevent that like I
didn't have time for these things when I
was in school I was doing football
practice I was doing Cross Country
Practice I went in early for a band you
know um I agree with you that sometimes
people only focus on one end of the
problem as a I hate to be that guy um
but as somebody that have you ever
watched The Wire sure I'm not going to
cite the wire's real life example but
like obviously there's only so much you
can do in a school When the Children
coming in are so beyond destroyed
because of the family life and
everything prior to them even getting to
school that day so I agree government is
not like the solution to Broken families
that would never be the case it's
actually not the solution to education
depending on the kind of solutions that
you're talking about some solutions yes
some solutions no yeah the only thing
I'm looking at is as I said earlier just
like these minimum threshold things
where it's like where can government
make because you mentioned marginal
which I think is a really good way to
look at things there's marginal cost and
marginal utility to things where the
first $1,000 per student you spend might
give you a huge return but the extra
20,000 after just these are all
pragmatic discussions actually this is
what we used to hash out in legislatures
before they turned into platforms for
people grandstanding but yes sure okay
yeah